hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play dead
space 3 we've got a wonderful scenic
view of death and destruction over the
years right here but enough getting
artistic let's get down to business we
got to find an antenna of some sorts to
plan a route so that they don't get
obliterated by the debris I'm guessing
I'm not really sure myself pop a few
these mines here get rid of them give me
some room to work with aha here's a
satellite right here all right let's get
business some engineering work as an
engineer I do appreciate this sort of
stuff by the way I think I found one of
those flight recorders great there
should be more floating around the
Roanoke ok I'll see what I can turn up
you got it bread I'm all about helping
out ok so I need to find more satellites
like that doesn't seem like my indicator
wants to put me towards it but whatevs
Bri I see it excuse me pardon me you
couldn't hit the broadside of an
elephant ha ha good god I was a bit too
close for comfort ok I see the two
satellites right there and they're
showing me too hard but I am and need
some of some oxygen like now like right
now where the hell is the oxygen ah ah
ha ha ah dudes and dudettes I am in need
of some oxygen right away where the hell
is it ok I think I see one over there ok
yes yes yes yes please get me please
give me please keep leave me give me
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme I'm
glad they finally mastered oxygen supply
for space in these fancy suits I mean I
think in the original dead space like
you only had like 45 seconds and I mean
that added a lot to the tension but it
wasn't very practical in terms of
space-age technology and all that jazz
ah
oh holy balls I thought that was gonna
be an insta-kill
that thing snuck up on me I didn't even
hear any of the warning things I just
heard that dull thing from the scavenger
BOTS finder I gotta get out of here it's
like a minefield out here hey Ellie I
think I have enough fly reporters to
reconstruct a safe route to the planet
okay what's next
I put her me interview obligation module
and then plug it into the shuttle I just
need to find a bench should be easy
enough that boot yeah okay so we just
need to find a bench and we're up and
out of here I'm gonna miss being in
space because I got a feeling after the
shuttle we're never gonna be in space
again maybe at the end of the game but I
like it out here I just like it it's
relaxing very peaceful I mean it's kind
of God know very ominous feeling but in
a weird way it's quite peaceful I like
it a lot
okay so I'm actually going inside the
roanoke to find a bench I believe I'll
be the only one on the Roanoke one I
like who else was there with me when I
was exploring the other ships or maybe
they're all in the Roanoke I have no
idea if so that one kid is out there on
his own ah
Faiza Clark can handle it I'm sure a
little inexperienced kid can do all
tarted up I'm actually out of med kits
surprisingly I definitely need to get to
a bench
all is lost ah that's a familiar
comforting thought
but I've been in more dire situations
than this let's see ah this suit kiosk
funda ba let's upgrade the rig
please sad like some more oh ma thank
y'all
yes oh that's all I can do damn it
somatic gel I spent too much on all much
other stuff okay
anyway I need um hell yeah I definitely
need another slot on that bad boy
definitely need duration up and that's
all I can do for that um I could do now
Cal save I'll save it for later
I've got a scrap bot waiting for me at a
bench so I'm sure there'll be a few more
stuff that I can do I shouldn't be
expecting - what the [ __ ] was that
alright then quarantine good looks like
they've been doing some cleanup on this
ship which is just kind of a good idea
when it's full of monsters okay got all
the flight recorders baby got a new
circuit scavenger BOTS all sorts of good
stuff going on seems good all right
let's pull all of my stuff I thought I
put more than that in there oh it's all
good I can make yeah I need the somatic
gel but I just got to be more careful
I'm not being not being careful enough
I'm just being reckless and endangering
whoo ah Oh
let's unlock some circuits here I've
already got to torque bars so I should
be fine sorry for all you British people
that I just flipped off okay I know I
got a rate of fire damage
yeah and then for this one damage clip
oh yeah oh yeah we should we should
indeed now let's plot a course for the
nearest shipping lane and get the hell
out of here all this we're going to the
planet are we I know that's how this all
started but we are in way over our heads
we can't take on a whole planet for
those goddamn things if not us then who
earth God is gone
rubble with the only ones left who can
do this and you know it Ellie
you have to admit it sounds crazy I mean
how do we know there's only a solution
down there because you told me in the
Admirals quarters
you said Canada and I think that's me
what we're going to do great captain we
can't head it Cup Carver I don't need
your mutiny on top of all this if I say
we're not going we're not going no
Ellie's right there's a shot here and
we're gonna take now you can come with
us or you can try to stop us but
remember around here well we're sted
than alive Ellie get the shuttle preps
I'm on my way
Oh badass Isaac Clark moving in charge
baby I'm the boss I'm surprised he is
quite you know confident in his
leadership like he makes a decision and
all sound that's it he's doing it
everyone else can go F themselves what
am I doing here
got the array transfer done yeah boy
navigation module installed from what
it's worth wait I'm not getting in ah
there it goes
and just in time looks like our flight
windows approaching okey-dokey oh come
on aboard all righty then how do I come
aboard
ah the other side of course of course
yeah the big door that looks like an
airlock of course it's it's all so
simple now let's get down to the planet
I'm sure all hell is about to break
loose cuz nothing ever goes according to
plan
well I'm glad to see you too what's that
look for
this is going to work right my windows
coming up we go now or not at all
hey what's up with the oxygen injector
sarcone they're now locked down I tried
but the threads are rusty let me see
what I can do if one of those pops loose
the cabin fire is gonna burn us up for
the atmosphere does any effect find the
pressure reading on the main console let
me know when I have a solid seal
oh it's such a happy reunion with these
two okay this one is dead that one is
dead also what am I doing here exactly I
guess no no I'm reinserting them and I'm
locking them up seems so simple
haha I got the Kinesis module apparently
and no one else does and it's steady
okey-dokey
I didn't know everyone else was already
here alright buddy let's get this done
Hiep activate launch cuz apparently I'm
the captain now
this is suicide those mines will rip
this ship apart it'll hold okay everyone
let's see if the same can fly few lines
all go sensors online I'm seeing mines
at 2,000 meters targeting computer
spinning up okay Isaac you have the
controls projecting optimal route now
try to keep it on course and shoot
anything that gets in the way
Buster's one-quarter floored okay I'm in
control the guns and I got up I
definitely got them watch out for that
thing things are looking a little bit
dicey oh I'm moving I got to move the
ship too
nail them down Isaac come on ba you got
this [ __ ] come on okay oh that's big
that is big that's what she said I'm
panicking I'm panicking I'm panicking
okay I'm okay
duh I'm Isaac Clark I got a hold on this
okay
all right so far so good everything not
going to hell just yet but we'll soon
enough oh that one almost go holy balls
there's so many of them that's also what
she said okay we're good ten seconds to
entry 8 just hold it on course if we hit
it at the wrong guy here's where the fun
begins
okay just shooting debris now holding it
of course holy gosh holy [ __ ] holding it
on course right into that okay right
all right things could not be more ideal
right through the middle baby [ __ ] miss
I missed I missed everybody's drunk eh
this is gonna be rough
we're coming in too hot Yuri
course-correction
we go this danger we won't reach the
wind up okay I'm sending you Andrew
Becker I hope I wasn't aah
it's right in front of me what are you
doing to me you're killing me man is it
it holes Oh golly
we're okay nobody panic
Isaac Clark's the only one allowed to
panic I'm off cards I know I'm of course
trying to get back on course
Oh
okay step aside professional badass
coming through watch me do my work
yep and no thing Oh such a badass
all right making my way downtown moving
fast in a blah blah Oh
oh poor guy
all right still maintaining our descent
into hell
Oh balls
we're bound to rebound rebound or boned
I mean we're okay no we're boned we're
bound [ __ ] we're bound
we're so boned we shall bone Oh God move
all this thing is agile like nobody's
business and by nobody business I mean
it is not agile at all [ __ ] okay
ah
hahaha so the whole ship separated off
okay man that was like that was amazing
and a whole sequence was amazing I was
like one of the most heart-pounding
like adrenaline sequences I've ever seen
ah this looks familiar
yeah
all right I am lost and alone and I'm
guessing my helmet is not working at my
body temperature is very important to me
which probably means that I got a
standby fire I'm gonna guess that
everybody assumes I'm dead which seems
like a pretty normal situation I mean
why wouldn't they
hello okay I got a survey charge not
exactly sure what that is for I am well
aware fires
no kidding fire is warm okay
Isaac's talking to himself again which
is a bad bad sign all right where am I
going here I don't even know this was
not part of the demo the only part of
the demo was that intro sequence there
where he was climbing out of the
capsized thingamabob er
whoo no no
what do you mean oh I see way in the
distance there that's the UM and that is
a pretty sight I mean although the death
and destruction and all the same but
that is a damn pretty sight I mean look
at that that is gorgeous
okay yeah Oh teammate Oh die oh [ __ ] me
I wish that surviving every life in that
situation was as easy as mashing the e
button not done yet
okay there we go oh right Ellie Ellie
are your boobs Sarah Ellie please tell
me your boobs are okay Ellie no I'll
miss those things
I'll miss something so much all right
back into the blizzard all right so I
don't exactly know we're looking for but
eventually we're gonna find some sort of
base that's just a guess or rather I
know that's gonna happen okay chasm need
to get across the chasm
yeah yeah is that a chair I like the
detail on the walls here I mean
seriously oh hello
is that haha scavenger BOTS out here I
am dropping temperature so you might
want to hurry the hell up okay whatever
you'll be waiting for me at the bench go
go go go go losing body temperature real
quickly I don't think the human body
drops temperature that quickly even
especially if you're in a suit like that
but whatever okay so this looks bad but
I mean they were in a bigger section of
the ship than I was
okay crazy
I guess when you've seen that much death
you can relieve that it's not your
precious Ellie but yeah it's not normal
to grab a slightly beheaded body and go
oh thank god but okay this is Isaac
Clark we're talking about duh Isaac
Clark badass professional Wow hello hi
what the hell
well that was surprising alright Ben I
guess I think didn't want to play all
right so all radio contact has been
severed we are in over our heads
don't really know what I'm looking for
here but I really need fire really
quickly
I'm guessing up here here we go come on
we're about I don't know Celsius that
well off the top of my head but I know
it's getting kind of cold for the human
body
I'm not exactly sure how far the core
temperature of the human body can go
before dying I know it's not that much
there we go there we go okay we're good
in a dilapidated bathroom here looking
good got some marker symbols there and
oh no wait no that's just a lady with
her legs in the air
looked like marker symbols duh I've seen
marker symbols everywhere they're
everywhere man
whoa what the where
okay looks almost nice here the bolas
gun le le le is that you are you in
right nope you're stuck in alone Isaac
so let's just tinker on our bench in
this Aloha festive place I guess okay I
got a blueprint from oldest gun whoa
sweep the leg what what are these whoa
there's the Bullis gun not sure what
that does exactly but I can't build it
obviously okay anyway I'm I'm all good
here I don't think I need anything else
I got everything's maxed out on my
weapon upgrade so I should be fine for
now this looks bad just like everything
else
why was anyone on this planet again was
this a homeworld for all the markers if
so who the hell lived here must have
been a long time ago when the Sun was in
a much better spot
and this seems like a pretty intensive
operation we OH - damage - one rate of
fire wow that's stupid that's stupid I
hate you
holy balls Jesus what the okay where is
that thing is that thing just poking at
me and waiting for me to get in a
position where I'm going to die
can I get I'm stuck in aiming mode I'm
stuck at aiming mode oh you gotta be
kidding me I'm stuck in a me I can't
sprint ah bug I found a bug can I get
out of a mning mode for the love of God
I can't sprint my body temperature is
dropping I'm in need well eat I'm
constantly prepared for you [ __ ] I
can't even stop now thank you please try
again where am I going I don't I can't
even navigate I can't even get off this
ladder I'm gonna die Oh baloney
this is the hole I'm stuck [ __ ] I get
dream for every room there's everything
wrong I'm gonna die I'm a freeze to
death right here I don't have a keycard
cuz I
hello thank you what's in here anything
nothing no shelter I'm gonna die well
I'm an idiot I eventually figured out
that it was my caps locks that was
keeping my aim up but I only figured
that out after I ended the game it took
me a lot longer than I thought it would
and I'm not gonna force you to watch
five minutes of me wandering around in
the snow
complaining about him a system that I am
at fault for breaking so I'm just going
to pick this up in the next episode so
here's the outro Roberto remover thank
you everybody so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
take this anymore